pour pas d'insectes au menu mais par
contre des livres assez surprenant parce
que deux jours après le centenaire de
l'armistice de 1918 tiphaine vous avec
qui on ne découvre régulièrement des
sélections livre vous êtes venus avec
des livres pour enfants qui parlent de
la guerre et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que c'est pas évident d'expliquer
à nos enfants ce qu'est la grande guerre
oui mais j'ai trouvé des livres il vient
très intéressant et le premier c'est une
bande dessinée vous la voyez ici ça
s'appelle la petite fille qui voulait
voir la guerre de jean-yves le naour et
christelle galant donc c'est publié aux
éditions grand angle et sa pâle figure
et vous de l'histoire parallèle entre
une petite clémence qui vit aujourd'hui
à charnay les mâcon dans notre région et
son aïeul qui s'appelait aussi clémence
et qui vivait en 1914 1918 et cette
clémence là c'était une petite fille
très intrépides qui ne comprenait pas
pourquoi elle n'avait pas de nouvelles
de son père qui lui étaient au front et
elle va tout faire pour essayer dans la
voir alors c'est une très belle histoire
puisque on suit clémence la clémence de
2018 en train de préparer son exposé qui
tombent sur des lettres de son aïeul et
on découvre la clémence de 1914 et la
vie de l'époque en fait la vie à
l'arrière celle d'août on parle pas
forcément souvent les privations les
femmes qui devaient se débrouiller un
petit peu tout seul c'est vraiment une
très jolie bande dessinée humaniste
voilà qui qui participent à ce devoir de
mémoire
et puis qui plaira beaucoup aux enfants
qui est aussi un petit peu féministe
donc ça m'a plu voilà metella entre les
mains de toutes les filles et des
garçons aussi voilà c'est à partir de 8
9 ans c'est très joli
c'est très émouvant voilà j'ai adoré
centrale et la petite fille qu'ils
voulaient voir la guerre de jean-yves le
naour et christelle la grand publié aux
éditions grand angle très très jolie
bande dessinée comme bien souvent une
très jolie bande dessinée en précède une
autre l'autre livre que vous avez choisi
se déroule cette fois pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale sur fond
d'occupation allemande dire oui parce
que je voulais pas vous parler seulement
de la première guerre mondiale je me
suis dit que finalement ce qui comptait
sur les histoires qui se passe pendant
la guerre c'était quand même l'amour
l'amitié
souvent c'est le fond de ces la trame de
fond de ces histoires là et dans l'ami
interdit de vincent dumas et il y en a
sur du camp publié aux éditions du
caïman et bien on découvre une grande
histoire d'amitié entre un petit garçon
georges qui a 12 ans qui commence un
apprentissage en cuisine et un officier
allemand qui s'appelle yoann est en fait
figurez-vous que devenir apprenti
cuisinier pendant la guerre en 1940
c'est pas évident parce qu'il ya pas
grand chose à cuisiner finalement mais
un jour il rencontre donc que yoann qui
lui a des boues produits à cuisiner et
qui lui dit écoute je vais t'apprendre
mois il faudra qu'on fasse ça en
cachette parce que être ami avec un
officier allemand pendant la guerre
c'est pas évident et j'ai bien aimé ce
livre là parce que des amitiés entre
français et allemands
bon il ya beaucoup d'histoires qui parle
de ça mais c'est là c'est fait pour les
enfants à partir de 8 ans donc à ses
jeunes lecteurs c'est au tour de la
cuisine du partage qu'on peut éprouver
en mangeant en cuisinant on retrouve
fabienne finalement avec ses tripes et
puis la chute est très très intéressante
puisqu'on va voir finalement toute la
complexité des sentiments humains elle
est totalement inattendue donc vraiment
je conseille ce livre c'est un très joli
roman d'apprentissage
voilà sur l'amitié l'amour et puis mon
mât la guerre aussi la seconde guerre
mondiale donc ça une petite piqûre de
rappel
l'ami interdit de vincent dubois qui
plaît aussi beaucoup à part aux impasses
que je sais pas si vous l'entendez mais
de temps en temps quand il fait quelques
petits bruits notre robot j'adore ce
regard est allé moi c'est un show qui
vous écoute
willy et ils nous regardent quand on
parle en fait c'est assez fascinant
parce qu'on l'a pas dit à chaque fois
qu'il entend la voix humaniste
comment tout à fait non c'est pas être
il ya un mode d'emploi de 50 pages c'est
un vrai robot émotionnel ça coûte pas
7000 euros pour rien en revanche le
bouquin de vous présenter pour les
enfants et que beaucoup moins ça nous
rassure pour notre porte-monnaie
c'est le suivant
il est toujours en temps de guerre on
suit les amours d'un fantôme c'est ça
oui les amours d'un fantôme en temps de
guerre de nicolas de crécy donc publié
aux éditions albin michel et celui-là je
voulais vous en parler parce qu'on ne
sait pas exactement quelle guerre c'est
en tout cas une guerre au pays des
fantômes et c'est un très joli livre qui
a obtenu le prix vendredi
donc c'est l'équivalent du prix goncourt
pour la littérature jeunesse donc rien
que ça et je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez
nicolas de crécy c'est c'est un auteur
de bande dessinée qui est très connu et
c'est la première fois qu'il fait un
roman illustré
donc il ya de magnifiques illustrations
voilà alors ça c'est le petit fantôme
alors déjà on a envie de le serrer dans
ses bras et de suivre ses aventures rien
que quand on le voit les illustrations
ressent un petit peu à des gravures de
gustave doré et vous voyez les fantômes
sont quand même pas très sympathique ça
c'est des fantômes assises qui ont pris
le pouvoir qu'ils mettent en place des
camps d'entraînement pour la jeunesse
qui volent des oeuvres d'art alors
évidemment ça fait penser à quelques
périodes sombres
voilà qui sont pas si lointaine et
l'auteur a voulu justement rappeler que
la démocratie c'est quelque chose
d'assez fragile qu'il faut choyer voilà
et qu'il faut quand même dix ont gardé
cette idée de solidarité et puis voilà
ne pas oublier que que ça fait du bien
de temps en temps de d'être de se serrer
les coudes et puis c'est pour les
lecteurs plus tôt adolescents et adultes
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de références
c'est très bien 6 et je vous le
conseille évidemment c'est pas des
lectures triste on parle d'amitié
d'amour de solidarité de liberté voilà
les amours d'un fantôme montant de
guerre c'est chez albin michel merci
pour cette sélection livre c'est pas
évident de parler d'événement comme ça à
des enfants